J'ai grandi dans une toute petite ville de campagne
dans l'Etat de Victoria.
J'ai eu une éducation tout à fait normale et tranquille.
J'allais à l'école, je traînais avec mes amis,
je me chamaillais avec mes plus jeunes sœurs.
Tout était extrêmement normal.
Quand j'avais 15 ans, un membre de ma communauté
a contacté mes parents
et voulait me nominer
au prix de la réussite de la communauté.
Mes parents ont répondu : « Hm, c'est très gentil,
mais il y a comme un petit problème avec ça.
Elle n'a vraiment rien réussi. » (Rires)
Ils avaient raison, vous savez.
J'allais à l'école, j'avais de bonnes notes,
j'avais un petit boulot tranquille après les cours
dans le salon de coiffure de ma mère,
je passais beaucoup de temps
à regarder « Buffy contre les Vampires » et « Dawson ».
Oui, je sais. Quel éclectisme !
Ils avaient raison, vous savez.
Je ne faisais rien qui ne sortait de l'ordinaire,
absolument rien.
Je ne faisais rien qui pouvait être considéré comme une réussite,
si l'on enlevait la question du handicap.
Des années plus tard, j'étais en deuxième cycle d'enseignement
dans un lycée de Melbourne,
et ça faisait 20 minutes que je donnais un cours de droit à des secondes
quand ce garçon a levé la main et dit :
« Hey, Mademoiselle, quand est-ce que vous allez commencer votre discours ? »
J'ai répondu : « Quel discours ? »
Vous voyez, je leur parlais
des lois sur la diffamation depuis près de 20 minutes.
Il a dit : « Vous savez,
votre discours de motivation.
Quand les gens en fauteuil roulant viennent à l'école,
ils disent souvent, des trucs inspirants ? »
(Rires)
« Souvent c'est dans le grand hall. »
C'est à cet instant que ça m'a frappée :
les seules expériences que ce gamin avait eues avec des handicapés
ne consistaient qu'à les voir comme des sources d'inspiration.
Nous ne le sommes pas, pour ce gamin,
ce n'est pas de sa faute, c'est vrai pour beaucoup d'entre nous.
Pour beaucoup d'entre nous, les handicapés ne sont pas nos professeurs,
nos docteurs ou nos manucures.
Nous ne sommes pas de vraies personnes. Nous sommes là pour inspirer.
En fait, je me tiens sur cette scène
avec mon look, dans ce fauteuil roulant,
vous attendez sûrement de moi
que je vous inspire. Non ? (Rires)
Oui.
Eh bien, mesdames et messieurs,
j'ai peur de vous décevoir de façon spectaculaire.
Je ne suis pas là pour vous inspirer.
Je suis ici pour vous dire que l'on vous a menti
au sujet des handicaps.
Oui, nous avons répandu ce mensonge disant que
les handicaps sont des Mauvaises Choses, avec un grand M et un grand C.
C'est une mauvaise chose et vivre avec un handicap
vous rend exceptionnel.
Ce n'est pas une mauvaise chose,
ça ne vous rend pas exceptionnel.
Au cours des dernières années, on a été en mesure
de propager ce mensonge encore plus loin
sur les réseaux sociaux.
Vous avez pu voir des images comme celle-ci :
« Le seul handicap dans la vie c'est d'avoir mauvais caractère »
Ou celle-ci : « Votre excuse est invalide ».
En effet.
Ou celle-là : « Essayez avant d'arrêter ! »
Ce ne sont que quelques exemples,
il y a beaucoup d'images de ce genre dehors,
Vous avez peut-être vu celle de la petite fille sans main
faisant un dessin avec un crayon qu'elle tient dans sa bouche.
Vous avez peut-être vu un enfant
courir avec des prothèses en fibres de carbone.
Ces images, il y en a beaucoup,
c'est ce qu'on appelle du porno inspirant.
(Rires)
J'utilise le terme porno délibérément,
parce qu'on objective un groupe de personnes
pour le bien d'un autre groupe de personnes.
Dans ce cas, nous objectivons les personnes handicapées
pour le bien-être des personnes valides.
L'objectif de ces images
est de vous inspirer, de vous motiver,
pour que vous les regardiez
et que vous pensiez : « Bon, aussi horrible que soit ma vie,
ça pourrait être pire.
Je pourrais être comme cette personne. »
Et si vous étiez cette personne ?
J'ai perdu le compte du nombre de fois
où un étranger est venu vers moi
pour me dire à quel point il pense que je suis courageuse ou inspirante,
c'était bien avant que mon travail
n'ait une quelconque visibilité.
Il me félicitait
de réussir à me lever le matin
et à me rappeler mon propre nom. (Rires)
C'est objectivant.
Ces images-ci et celles-là
objectivent les personnes handicapées
au bénéfice des personnes valides.
Elles sont ainsi pour que vous puissiez les regarder,
vous dire que les choses ne sont pas si mauvaises,
pour mettre vos inquiétudes dans une nouvelle perspective.
La vie en temps que personne handicapée
est en réalité quelque peu difficile.
Nous surmontons effectivement des épreuves.
Mais les choses que nous surmontons
ne sont pas celles auxquelles vous pensez.
Ce ne sont pas des choses liées à nos corps.
J'utilise le terme « handicapé » vraiment délibérément,
parce que je participe à ce qui s'appelle le modèle social de l'handicapé,
qui dit que nous sommes plus handicapés
par la société dans laquelle on vit
que par nos corps et nos diagnostics.
Donc, je vis dans ce corps depuis un bout de temps.
Je l'aime bien.
Il fait les choses dont j'ai besoin,
j'ai appris à l'utiliser au mieux de ses capacités,
tout comme vous,
et c'est ça aussi pour les enfants sur les photos.
Ils ne font rien d'extraordinaire.
Ils utilisent simplement leurs corps
au meilleur de leurs capacités.
Donc, est-ce vraiment juste de les objectiver
de la façon dont nous le faisons, en partageant ces images ?
Les gens, quand ils disent : « Vous m'inspirez, »
ils le voient comme un compliment.
Je sais pourquoi ça arrive.
Parce que c'est un mensonge, on nous a vendu
ce mensonge qui dit qu'être handicapé vous rend exceptionnel.
Honnêtement, c'est faux. Je sais ce que vous vous dites.
Je suis là à vous mettre l'inspiration dans un sac,
et vous pensez : « La vache, Stella,
tu n'as jamais été inspirée par quelque chose ? »
Le fait que oui, ça m'arrive.
J'apprends constamment des autres personnes handicapées.
Je n'apprends pas que je suis plus chanceuse qu'eux,
J'apprends que c'est une idée géniale d'utiliser une pince à barbecue
pour ramasser les choses qu'on a laissé tomber. (Rires)
J'apprends ce truc génial pour charger
la batterie de son téléphone portable grâce à celle de son fauteuil.
Génial.
Nous apprenons de la force et de l'endurance des autres,
pas contre nos corps ou nos maladies,
mais contre le monde qui nous rend exceptionnel
et nous objective.
Je pense que c'est ce mensonge qu'on nous a servi
sur le handicap qui est la plus grande des injustices.
Ça rend notre vie difficile.
Et cette citation : « Le seul handicap dans la vie,
c'est un mauvais caractère. »
pourquoi est-ce une connerie ?
parce que c'est faux tout simplement,
à cause du modèle social du handicap.
Des sourires n'ont jamais transformé
un escalier en rampe d'accès.
Jamais. (Rires) (Applaudissements)
Sourire à l'écran de télévision ne va pas faire apparaître
les sous-titres pour les personnes sourdes.
Aucune manifestation au beau milieu d'une librairie
en diffusant des ondes positives ne va transformer ces livres en braille.
Ça ne se passe pas comme ça.
Je veux vivre dans un monde
où les handicaps ne sont pas des exceptions, mais la norme.
Je veux vivre dans un monde où une fille de quinze ans
qui passe son temps dans sa chambre à regarder « Buffy contre les vampires »
n'est pas considérée comme quelqu'un qui réussit
parce qu'elle est coincée dans un siège.
Je veux vivre dans un monde
où les attentes envers les personnes handicapées
ne sont pas si basses
qu'on nous félicite de nous lever
et de nous rappeler de notre nom le matin.
Je veux vivre dans un monde où l'on valorise les vraies réussites
des personnes handicapées,
et je veux vivre dans un monde
où un gamin de seconde d'un lycée de Melbourne
n'est absolument pas surpris
que sa nouvelle professeur soit en fauteuil roulant.
Un handicap ne vous rend pas exceptionnel,
mais remettre en cause ce que vous pensez en connaître.
Merci.
(Rires)